the American people may have deemed
Hillary Clinton and Donald Trump the
most unpopular presidential candidates
ever but they're the only candidates
we'll see on stage at the first debate
but what about him or her us well the
Commission on Presidential Debates a
private corporation that calls the shots
says they aren't allowed and if that
sounds pretty shady to you it's because
it is leading up to the first debate
Libertarian candidate Gary Johnson's
polling average has been about 9% Green
Party candidate Jill Stein about three
percent for a third party candidate to
be invited to the debates though they
have to be hitting 15% in the polls
according to the Commission's rules but
considering the fact that third party
candidates already face an uphill climb
with lack of media coverage and less
fundraising power that 15% requirement
is pretty unreasonable in fact it's
locked out third party candidates for
more than 20 years the last candidate to
join the major parties on stage was Ross
Perot in 1992 and it made a difference
Perot ended up with 19% of the vote in
the general election but excluding other
candidates isn't what the American
public wants 76 percent think that a
third party candidate should be included
if they're certified by a majority of
state ballots so what's the deal with
this commission that holds the keys to
the debates well the group claims it's
nonpartisan but it's board is made up of
GOP and Democratic insiders as well as
bankers and university presidents mostly
folks who have a vested interest in
keeping the two-party system as deeply
entrenched as it is it wasn't always
this way
the League of Women Voters a group whose
goal is to expand political
participation for all Americans used to
control the debate process they were all
sorts of badass and made sure that
candidates and parties weren't
controlling the process in 1980
President Jimmy Carter refused to attend
the debates because independent
candidate John Anderson was allowed on
stage but the league insisted on the
debate anyway and even threatened to set
out an empty chair to make sure the
public knew that Carter was refusing to
participate Carter didn't go he lost
that year a few elections later in 1988
the Democratic and Republican parties
secretly met and presented the league a
memo detailing who they thought should
be allowed to attend the debate and even
tried to ban follow-up questions the
League of Women Voters thought that was
super sketch so here's what they did we
have
no intention or becoming an accessory to
the hood winking of the American public
under these circumstances the league is
withdrawing its sponsorship and so the
Commission on Presidential Debates was
born and the Democratic and Republican
parties got what they wanted that brings
us to today we're only the powerful and
wealthy two parties get a chance to
debate in front of a national captive
audience
it is a rigged game he may not know what
Aleppo is but the man's got a point